joel ryan the 34th pitcher used this
year by the minnesota twins his stats
are brought to you by home furniture
aaa stats there making his major league
debut that is a moment that he will
never forget hopefully he's got those
nerves under control i think he's going
to be okay he's got a pretty good
pedigree uh especially what he's gone
through the last couple weeks pitching
uh for team usa in the olympics northern
california native
short center field
buxton started back came in
and ryan gets his first major league
hitter on the short fly ball
good command of it he's he's shown good
command throughout his minor league
career i think that's the one thing to
keep an eye on tonight with a guy
anytime a guy's making his debut and
young guy
fly ball right center field
ref schneider over two away so two fly
ball outs induced by ryan and here comes
ian happ
well i'm not sure the first inning could
have gone any better and down goes half
on a fastball in 93
and there's the first big league
strikeout for joe ryan and there's a
keepsake for joel for the rest of his
life justin steele out here making his
fourth start and really plenty of work
this year but stretched him out as a
starter steel's last timeout was against
colorado on august 25.
on the ground backhanded alcantara good
arm buxton can fly out at first when you
can adjust and be able to throw a little
bit of a wrinkle in a little bit of
movement get some weak contact
popped up they converge
and there is roma to deal with the
veteran donald suit
they have the shift on there and romaine
gathers it in donaldson is out that will
be scored as a four to three foot out
two down down at schwendell no score top
of the third runners at second and third
that is crushed
left field and forget it frank
schwindell a three-run homer and just
like that the cubs on top on a rocket by
frank the tank is eight i mean that was
a bolt to left field we talk about a lot
of swing and miss and joe ryan's
fastball will frank schwendell gets one
up and in kind of right in the loading
zone pulls the hands in and absolutely
tattoos another ball three balls and two
strikes
so hayward
fastball in a better spot lazy fly ball
to center
boston with the catch one away austin
roma early in account
to right field
and ref schneider coming in
and a quick second out
danelle alfonso
much better fourth inning for joe ryan
on an o2 pitch he came up with a
change-up and a three-up three-down
inning for joe ryan getting those swings
and misses and finding his way through
the lineup and through his first big
league start i think he's done a pretty
good job so far it'll be on contra
drops one on the outside corner a slow
breaking ball a call third strike one
away
talked about his curveball being a pitch
that he would more throw early in the
count
he saw one other one to hayward that was
a ball that one there good action on
that pitch starts outside it
probably a little bit outside but home
plate on bruce jackman tonight has been
a little bit generous on that outside
corner he's got a lot of options now
with that getting ahead with a curveball
you can throw a breaking bubble below
the strike zone we haven't seen a
fastball yet so he could elevate one
there shattered his back no roller to
second
throws him out
he went with the curveball below the
strike zone trying to count the pieces
and laying on the field right now looks
like maybe three pieces so good from joe
ryan take a look at that not quite 12-6
he gets around it a little bit but
good still gets good downward action
and now six in a row sent down by ryan
two down ortega the matter two short fly
balls to buxton
another short fly to center field
bunkston coming in joel ryan's completed
five innings in his major league debut
and there is a one two three inning
for joe ryan nice job here to advert
also makes his first relief appearance
of this season last time he pitched in
relief was
september of last year and our pitching
change brought to you by lakeside bank
he's coming back from that hamstring
injury
yeah and this is a good opportunity you
know they've talked about managing his
indian innings you have them come in out
of the bullpen after the lefty you go
righty real good fastball slider combo
we've seen it all year
four seamer in and then two seamer away
wisdom bare hands throw to first pick
out at first
talk about smooth
well you know he's got a great arm and
soft hands at first for reebos pretty
good combo right there
you badly wanted to but unfortunately he
just can't do that
here's our all stan allstate good hands
replay
wisdom read this so well he got a great
jump on that ball
gets down there with the bare hand and
he knows who's got it first base
that's right the man with the slick
glove
reevos picks it out of the dirt
able to nail him by a half a step the
twins have been shut out on two hits
here tonight
there's a swing and a miss and alzolai
gets a tough customer in a rise
one down last of the eighth inning cubs
on top three to nothing
fastball bounced to short feeling by
alcantara
you'll throw to first and that's out
number two
i think that word that taylor used via
david ross calm in the outfield that's a
great way to describe it there
makes the play
and advert also i just molded them down
one two three a nine pitches
on to the bottom of the ninth cubs three
twins nothing and now it's advert also
has gotten nine outs on 24 pitches
that'll face rob ref snyder
in there got him looking through two
sliders in the dirt that he didn't offer
at he said all right i'll just throw in
for a strike then short quick
3-2 rough snider with no chance on that
well executed by al's lie and you
mentioned it the stuff has ticked up
elzalei always works from the stretch
even with nobody on
off the side of the mound there to
gather it in andrew roma
the bullpen sure has been good haven't
they been big and now big miguel ceno
owls
three and two two outs bases empty here
comes
swing and a miss struck him out
ball game cubs win
owls alive brilliant out of the pen
frank the tank goes yard and justin
steele
his first
big league win as a starter
you